we've been talking about energy bills do
you welcome Liz trusser saying that she
is going to be focusing on trying to
bring people's bills down or trying to
help people with their bills and also
cause those supply issues
well Sophie nothing I've heard from this
trust or the conservatives over the
summer suggests they have a real plan
whether it's dealing with soaring energy
bills rocketing fuel Bills or the NHS
crisis they don't seem to get it and
they don't seem to care so from the
liberal Democrat perspective the sooner
we get concerted out of government the
better
what kind of prime minister do you
expect Liz trust to be it feels like
she's gone through you know various
different incarnations I guess in her
time in Westminster but certainly we've
got a very solid view in the campaign
but how do you expect her to govern
well at the moment she's been speaking
to the right of the conservative party
into conservative members she's not been
speaking to the country she thinks that
although her proposed tax cuts would
favor the most wealthy that that's fair
when you've got people struggling
millions of families and pensioners on
on you know low and middle incomes
really need help and she's favoring the
most wealthy you know she's set her mind
against attacks on the oil and gas
companies who are making huge profits
tens of billions of pounds of profits
because President Putin invaded Ukraine
surely a British prime minister should
be saying let's have a fair system let's
ask these oil and gas companies who are
making billions of pounds of profit on
the back of Putin's illegal Invasion get
them to help pay for the source of
support that millions of families and
pensions need that's what liberal
Democrats would do I've seen no sign
from this trust or conservative that
they're going to do that oh they care
about these people
we'll find out a bit more of course
about her policy and platform in the
coming days and weeks she's promised
Amnesia action or certainly action in
the next week when it comes to energy
bills and there is a feeling among some
particularly of course in labor there
needs to be a general election a West
streeting told me earlier that she needs
to get her own mandate if she wants to
deviate Too Much from the manifesto on
which Boris Johnson was elected the lib
Dems on an election footing
uh yeah I mean first of all we do need
to pass legislation in Parliament to to
put a cat to freeze the energy bills
this October we have to provide help now
that come in really quickly there's a
liberal Democrat idea that they probably
now supports here others support it if
we did that then there should be an
election as soon as possible after that
as long as we give the help to millions
of families and pensioners and to
businesses get that in place then let's
have an early general election get rid
of these conservatives who don't seem to
have the answers our country needs
Boris Johnson of course is currently
enjoying his last day as prime minister
many things have been said about him but
the one thing is for sure is that he was
a election winner who do you fear more
at a general election Liz truss or Boris
Johnson
I'm looking forward to the next general
election he won't be Boris Johnson of
course uh it will be Liz truss and we'll
see what she actually does but if you
judge her by what she said she doesn't
seem to have a plan she doesn't seem to
have the ideas that are going to help
people with the soaring cost of living
with us energy bills with food prices
she had nothing to say about our NHS
system and our care system so you know I
I think when she gets to the election we
can debate her I'm increasingly
confident that liberal Democrats will
have the arguments to persuade people
who previously voted conservatives to
come and join us we did that in the last
year didn't we with boys Johnson's prime
minister we won three historic
by-elections feeding the services in
True Blue buckinghamshire and chesham
lamisham by election and then in
Christmas and a seat that serves to help
for 200 years in North Shropshire then
in East Devon uh earlier this summer so
liberal Democrats have shown that we can
persuade former lifelong concerted
voters to switch to the liberal
Democrats and that's what I hope to do
in the next general election with this
trust as the Tory leader
okay uh Sarah debut thank you very much
indeed thank you for coming on the
program today